[Applause]
something very important i want to share
with you a few points i want you to
consider you guys
and also our brother mo salah i think
the mole stands for muhammad and
other famous muslim influencers who are
celebrating christmas posting pictures
online with themselves with their
families with christmas trees
i mean it's very important we talk about
this in a kind and respectful manner
as these are people who are looked up to
and they have millions
of millions of followers massive amount
of followers this can create some
confusion potentially in the hearts of
many people
when they see them posting these types
of pictures no matter who they are
so we want to help clear some of the
confusion we also have to remember like
mo salah especially
even with such an amazing name he holds
a great responsibility
when people would see him make sajdah
this is the prostration just like
jesus would make moses would would make
and the last of our messenger sent to
mankind prophet muhammed peace and
blessings to be upon them all they would
make this sajdah this prostration to the
one and only creator that happens in the
earth
and after scoring a goal and this would
have a tremendous
impact on the not yet muslims out there
and the non-muslims out there
many would be singing songs how they
want to be muslims
his talent and faith even inspired a
local english man to become muslim
and salla's presence in liverpool alone
has led to a decrease in hate crimes
towards muslims
man just one small thing like this look
how great that was
an amazing impact that had now imagine
how many people this positively
influenced so the same way
that has a strong impact these type of
pictures and this type of message
also has a strong impact so that's why
we wanted to touch upon a few points
to have him consider more salon other
famous
influencers number one is we often just
think
we utter words we had our statements and
we don't think
of the severity the impact that words
can have i mean
we know just by one word a person can
break a marriage just one word
and by one word a person can save a
relationship
you know there's in the quran god
almighty allah is telling us not a word
does he or she utter but there is a
watcher by him ready to record it
i mean this is how severe it is that
there are angels appointed over you
marking down all the words that you say
so are those words we have to ask are
they pleasing to allah
or are they displeasing to allah the
almighty here's something else to
consider imagine
and i did a program on this and i want
to invite you guys to watch it it'll be
in the
description in the comments in the
description of this video and also in
the comments
because we went into extensive detail we
covered this topic in a reaction video
to muslims celebrating
christmas so i really i really
would love for most a lot to watch this
program right with this i mean i'm just
touching upon a few things
for him to consider in others imagine if
there was a holiday being celebrated
today and then people
people uncovered that it was connected
somehow to the holocaust
and we know how many people died there
would people be still
excited to celebrate this imagine if
there was
a holiday connected to 9 11
or anything else that was a tragedy
something tragic
that affected so many people's lives and
then people somehow
the pr machine got behind it and they
ended up beautifying it
and then they said oh that was in the
past but now in the present you know
it's about bringing families together
but the foundation was built on that so
people how would people react to that
but i mean why when it comes to allah
when we talk about [ __ ]
associating partners with allah
something that's based on that
when we look at the history of this
event and we have so many christians
running away from this because they know
the roots of it
and how it's connected to paganism but
why are we muslims
running towards it then is it because we
are more interested in pleasing the
people rather than pleasing allah
this had me thinking about what the last
and final messenger sent to mankind
muhammad said he said look pay attention
please whoever sought the pleasure of
allah
though it was displeasing to the people
then allah becomes
pleased with him and he will make the
people pleased with him
but on the contrary whoever sought the
pleasure of the people though it was
displeasing to allah
then allah becomes displeased with him
and will make the people displeased with
him brothers and sisters
it's very important that we get grounded
in our deen
then we won't make blunders like this
because these are things imagine
everybody will enter jannah one by one
some might have to spend some time in
jahannam
may allah protect us from that that's
why we want to stay away from the major
sins
we want to make tawba and be people of
toba of repentance not associating any
partners of allah
and staying away from things that di
please our creator before we meet our
creator
but there's one thing that will not be
forgiven is shook
so we want to stay away from anything
that comes close to it resembles in any
way shape or form
imagine you're going on a trip and
you've been planning on this trip
you're looking forward to this trip and
now you get to the border and you know
they told you no problem you were
qualified to enter
but there is just one thing that if you
carry this
with you you will not enter the country
but now you go ahead and bring this
thing whose fault is it so if allah
it is this is the thing that we need to
stay away from
we need to be on the pure monotheism we
need to be well grounded in the tohit
and we need to stay far away from the
things that are
displeasing to our creator before we
meet our creator because he's ultimately
the one who sets the rules and the
boundaries
and how we're going to know those rules
and boundaries how we're going to
worship allah the almighty properly we
have to know him
we have to know his deen we have to be
well grounded in a deen
so i invite our brother mo salah and
other influencers and people who are
celebrating this holiday and even the
not yet muslims out there who we want
the best for
because this is why we do these programs
to educate the masters to educate the
people
with love and mercy in mind so please
watch this program that we just did
on this specific top in the video
description in the comments watch it we
go into the history we go into the
common questions
we really go into and reacting to many
muslims celebrating this
and we give a proper response so it
behooves you
to watch this latest episode that we did
specifically on this topic it's
very important and again this is
something that is extremely important
and this is out of our love for our
brothers and sisters
and we pray for them all for most a lot
for all the others that may allah use us
for the good
that we can potentially do in spreading
this message of peace and purpose this
deen and being great ambassadors to it
thank you very much jazakallah salaam
alaikum
got